bassam bonjour en quoi consiste cette
troisième phase de déconfinement
effectivement de rose c'est aujourd'hui
que la tunisie entame sa troisième phase
du des continents suite à cette pandémie
qui coronavirus les déplacements qui
étaient interdits contre les régions
depuis le début du continent depuis le
début de la mise en place du couvre feu
par le gouvernement tunisien s'est élevé
à partir de ce matin ont quelques
misères vont pouvoir se dépasser entre
les régions ce qui va faciliter à
certaines personnes de pouvoir reprendre
du travail notamment ceux qui sont
amenés à se déplacer ou alors encore on
va visiter leurs familles entre le nord
et le sud
les frontières comme vous l'avez précisé
sont ouvertes à partir du 27 et les
tunisiens qui sont établis à l'étranger
pour gagner la tunisie mais sur
certaines conditions à savoir sept jours
d'isolement de confinement dans un hôtel
suivi de sept jours de confinement
obligatoire advance il est ce qui fait
quatorze jours de confinement la même
règle qui a été établi depuis le début
de cette crise du cornât des russes en
tunisie le bo nouvelle poitrine c'est
aux répliques des cafés les restaurants
que les mosquées les lieux de culte
compte ouvrir un soulagement pour pas
mal de commerçants qui ont été bloqués
en train d'arrêter leurs activités
depuis le début du continent ce qui a
été difficile pour certains dans la
mesure où le gouvernement tunisien a eu
du mal quand même à pallier à ce manque
que financier de certains commerces
notamment les restaurants les bars et
les cafés faut savoir qu'en tunisie
énormément de personnes ont l'habitude
d'être dehors de t'apporter les cafés et
les restaurants ce qui est un manque à
gagner énorme pour ces commerçants donc
la réouverture des restaurants des cafés
et des bars a lieu à partir de ce matin
ce qui va permettre une reprise
d'activité progressive mais une
réouverture sous certaines conditions
car ces personnes ces commerçants et
restaurateurs sont alités appliquer
encore les gestes barrières et puis des
mesures de distanciation donc ça va être
une reprise d'activité progressive donc
les tunisiens sont invités c'est quand
même à maintenir non certains
comportements et certaines attitudes
pour éviter toute relance
de ces virus il faut savoir que la
tunisie a enregistré aujourd'hui sont qu
un neuvième décès 49 décès au total
depuis le début de la pandémie
ce qui est un nombre très très faible
par rapport à ce qu'on a pu voir dans
d'autres pays notamment les pays voisins
comme l'algérie et la tunisie le
gouvernement se félicite d'avoir
anticipé un petit peu cette crise
sanitaire en mettant en place un
couvre-feu et puis en mettant en place
un continent assez rapides donc les
mesures ont été prises à partir de ce
matin on va voir ce que ça va donner
dans le courant de la journée
on a pu échanger et notamment hier avec
certains commerçants qui étaient
vraiment heureux de pouvoir reprendre
leurs activités cas pour beaucoup c'est
un manque à gagner énorme et la tunisie
a même déclaré que l idée une récession
très importante depuis même son
indépendance en 1956 dont la troisième
phase à partir d'aujourd'hui mais les
frontières resteront fermés jusqu'au 27
et qu'un volet précisé 27 des étrangers
les touristes pourront revenir en
tunisie ce qui soulagent un petit peu le
monde hôtelier qui permet à eu peur à
part à cette pandémie de revivre un
scénario catastrophe comme la tunisie
avait pu vivre pendant les attentats de
soude notamment le tourisme avait été
largement frappés faut savoir que chaque
midi dit énormément du tourisme et a
besoin de ces étrangers pour pouvoir
maintenir un type sur cette étude merci
beaucoup
bassam uscb en direct de tunis pour
toutes ces précisions